Demon Slayer season 3 covered the
swordsmith village Arc which takes up 30
chapters in the manga the season had 11
episodes in it but the first and last
episodes were twice as long as a regular
episode so let's say 13 regular episodes
equals 30 manga chapters the next Arc in
the manga is the hashira training Arc
but that's a short Arc with only nine
chapters this means that Demon Slayer
season 4 will cover at least a part of
the most epic Arc in the entire story
The Infinity Castle Arc this Arc
includes the battles against akaza Doma
and kokucible which are the best fights
in the series if season 4 has 26
episodes like season 1 did it could
easily cover both hashida training and
infinity Castle but if we get another
short season then we'll only get to the
first part of infinity Castle either way
I can't wait for season 4. for all the
latest Demon Slayer season 4 updates
subscribe to anime Opera right now